[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a digital pcr based protocol to
detect and quantify rna editing events
at hot spots
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
remy busan assistant professor
biological chemistry university of
california irvine school of medicine
dr busan you may now begin your
presentation
hi good morning everyone so today i'm
going to present some of the work we did
in my lab using the digital pcr to
detect and quantify rna editing events
at specific hotspots
before to introduce you about what we
did
with the digital pcr essay i'm going to
talk a little bit of what we are doing
in the lab currently
so malab is interesting in this family
of protein called apobac these proteins
are enzymes that promote the damination
of cytosine to uracil on rna or dna
and the main function of this enzyme
is to protect our cells against a viral
infection it's part of our innate immune
system so basically when you have a
virus that penetrates in our cells the
cells start to express aprobat proteins
and now this upper back protein is going
to target the rna or dna genome from
this virus to promote mutation and to
block the replication of these virus
however in many cancer
cancer cells deregulate the expression
of apple back proteins especially alpha
bacteria and aprobiotb leads to an over
regular over expression of alpha
bacteria and alphabet tree b and cancer
cells
and this over expression of hyperbaric
reality b now go into to leave an
accumulation of mutation in the genome
of these cancer cells and this mutation
going to promote cancer progression drug
resistance and metastasis so in my lab
we're interesting to understand how
these acrobatic proteins for bacteria
and this mutation in cancer and what
what are the consequences for the cancer
cells to accumulate so uh this mutation
and this biophobic treatment or
probability
so how it works to quickly summarize
apparatus only targets singles from dna
this thing has benzene can be formed
during dna replication transcription or
many different dna repair processes
in appropriate we are going to target
cytosine only cytosine that have a t
before the c is very important to have a
terminal before the c in order to
promote the determination of the
cytosine to uracil
then the uracil is going to be removed
by ung2 a uracil dna hycosylase to
create anabasic site this about excel is
going to be reaper if it's not correctly
repaired it's going to lead to an
accumulation of mutation in the genome
of
the cells and this mutation can be
detected by sequencing and usually they
are c to g or c to t mutation
dropper bacteria and laboratory b are
often overexpressed in cancer for this
reason we tried to develop strategy to
specifically target cancer cells that
express upper bacteria and appropriately
and to try to specifically kill these
cancer sex with as
different drug treatments and to make a
long story short what we identified we
identified that treating the cell with
rtr inhibitors can sensitize the cells
that express aquabacque so for example
in this
graph when we express a probability
using a dox and disabled promoter
these cells that express about bacteria
here in red are very sensitive to rtr
inhibitors
however if we express the catalytic dead
version of hyperbaric 2a subtrained
mutations that destroy the active site
of the proteins these cells are not any
more sensitive to anti-iron inhibitors
so we use an example to illustrate how
we can specifically target cancer cells
that express apple bacteria using here
and atr inhibitors
so the next goal now is to try to
identify these tumors that express
acrobatic to be able to target them with
an rtr inhibitors and thus can be
challenging because upper bacterial
expression is is very transient during
the development of the tumor probate2a
is constantly expressed following
different stresses leading over time to
this accumulation of mutation in the
cancer genome so when we collect the
tumor and seconds the tumor we don't
necessarily detect upper bacterial
expression where we're going to detect
upper bacteria and discrimination
so here our goal was to develop a method
to quickly
detect if a cancer says a tumor can
express aprobactory as ongoing activity
of a bacteria and to do so in a
way that is faster and and not as time
consuming as a second synthetic
so to do that we use the fact that upper
bacteria do not only target dna but also
rna to promote rna editing
so we analyzed in thousand and thousand
of patient tumor samples
uh iron editing event induced by appleby
to identify the sites that are
specifically edited by aprobacture and
we identified hundreds of sites in these
patient tumors that are specifically
edited by probability two of the most
edited sites that we don't define in
this patient are located in ddos in
cyfp1 genes and you can see here this
gene this this
site
i hid it in a
rna that form a specific structure is
from a hairpin
with a loop of four nucleotides and the
uc site is inside the loop the uc side
is targeted by acrobatic vf and you can
see inside the loop the sequence inside
the loop is very conserved between both
sides and that's because
this uh subscript this this side from a
perfect substrate for upper back rear
activity and this is why patients always
accumulate uh mutations at this position
so because apparently on always targets
this gene at this position we can now
develop a specific assay to monitor iron
editing event at this
precise location
to do so we develop we develop a digital
based
digital pcr based essay to monitor our
background activity at a ddr site in
this essay what we're doing we collect
rna from a cancer cell or patient tumor
samples that is edited or not by alpha
between we retrotranscribe to dna using
rt pcr
then we're going to use the tag-man
asset to monitor iron editing at this
dds position
we're going to use two probes together
one probe is going to recognize the
y-type sequence of dds with the x404 the
second probe is going to recognize the
mutated version of dds with a farm flow
of form
and we will at the same time we're going
to use two primers that going to amplify
the regions between
that contain the edited site
and during the amplification the polymer
is going to degrade the probe to release
the quencher and now we can detect the
fluorescence so it's going to be the x
or the fan depending of the template dna
but before to start the pcr reaction
we're going to separate the pcr in a
thousand and thousands of partition in a
way that each partition contains one dna
complex
and only then we're going to start the
amplification so depending of the
template present inside the partition
we're going to have amplification of the
y-type seconds or the mutated seconds
using the probes that recognize the
y-type seconds or the mutated seconds
and so we're going to have two different
fluorophore
depending of the template dna present in
the partition so at the end we just
analyze the ratio between bars 404 to
determine the percentage of rna editing
so the plate look like this one where we
have a 16 sample inside the plates and
each samples contain a macro array array
and this microchamber array contains a
20 000 macro chamber where the dna
template going to be
one dna template going to be present in
each macro chamber
so before to use our samples we wanted
to optimize our pcr reaction to do so we
use a synthetic synthetic
oligonucleotide
that mimic ddr seconds the y type
sequence of details or the mutated
sequence of ddos
so when we use the y type sequence of
ddrs we can see the amplification using
the white eye probe
only but not the mutated probe
when we use synthetic oligonucleotides
with
mutant on it we can only see the
amplification of the mutated
details using the probes i recognize the
edited version of details when we
incubate both probes together t and a
template together we can see the
amplification
using both probes suggesting that this
essay is very specific and even we have
only one nucleotide difference between
the two probes each probe can recognize
specifically the y type or the mutated
mutated seconds of dds
so now we validate our pcr sl we can
apply to our samples that express
acrobatic va
so we collect rna from u2s cells that
express alphabet qa and we run our
digital pcr essay and we can detect the
amplification of y-type ddos and mutated
tedious
and it's very specific because now if we
express a catalytic dead version of a
probability
we only see the amplification of the
y-type details and not the mutated
details
so here's the quantification and again
you can see that we can detect an
editing event
only when a probability a wild type is
expressed but not the catalytic dead
version so it's a very specific asset to
monitor ongoing activity of obituary in
a samples
in parallel we
did we performed the same essay in
another type of platform
in this platform we instead of separate
the pcr reaction in a defined macro
chamber we separate as a pcr reaction in
different droplets and but after that is
the same principle each row plate going
to contain different template dna and
after the amplification we calculate the
ratio of fluorescence between the
different droplets to establish a
percentage of rna editing in the samples
when we compare the two methods we
observe exactly the same results
both methods give us the same percentage
of rna editing events in our samples
so we can use both method to detect
ongoing activity of a battery
of our bacteria so now i'm going to show
you example of how we study an editing
activity and this type of aq using one
or the other method because both
give us the same results
the first question we ask is can we
apply our digital pcr method to monitor
androgenous level of acrobat ui in
cancer cells
and it was very challenging until now to
detect androgenous activity of a
probature because the expression level
of upper bacteria is extremely low in
cancer cells and so until now we were
not able to monitor directly endogenous
levels of upper bacteria in cancer
so to know if our digital pcrs was able
to do to do it
we select a panel of cancer cell lines
that express different levels of upper
back qa or upper back to be we wanted to
compare to upper between b because
appropriate vb is expressed about 100
times more at higher levels than upper
back to get and we wanted to make sure
that our digital pc rsa can
differentiate the activity of rocker
battery versus appropriate 2b
so we run our digital pcr sa and we were
able to detect rna editing activity only
in the two cell lines that expressed
acrobatic va but not in the cell lines
that express above atp
to confirm this result we use also rna
editing we measure a merger iron editing
activity in a different target cy of p1
and again we were able to detect
rna-editing activity only in the two
cell lines that express upper bacteria
so this result suggests that this
digital pcrsa is very specific to a
probability activity and can only detect
apobacteria activity and it's also very
sensitive because now we can directly
monitor endogenous level of apotheca
then we ask is it the is this method is
better than other methods used to study
aprobacteria such like qpcr that is a
current method used by people in the
field to monitor upper bacteria in
cancer
to do so we treat the cell with
adjunctiveness and interferon alpha to
induce upper bacterial expression in
these cells and you can see by qpcr we
have a strong induction of the mrna
level of alphabetical after treatment
with giant satabin and interferon alpha
and we observe also this increase of
activity when we look at digital pcrs
and also as a protein level by western
blood we can see the increase of protein
level of object after treatment with
transcetability and interferon alpha
so we then i ex
we then
um
release the cell in fresh media that do
not contain any margin sata being an
interferon alpha and quickly after the
release in fresh media the expression
level at mrna level decrease almost to
the basal level
surprisingly by digital pcr we were not
able to detect this decrease of upper
back reactivity after the release in the
fresh media
and we also confirmed that after at the
protein level by western blood apparatus
stay high in the cells even 72 hours
after a release in french media because
appleby is very it is a very stable
protein so even it's not the mrna is not
present anymore the proteins stay in the
cell for a very long time so it's an
example how
uh using the digital pcr isa it's a
better and better method to monitor
ongoing activity of a
because the mrna level do not reflect
necessarily the state
of the cells at this time and upper
bacteria can be present but not at the
mrna level and so using digital pcr
assay in this case it's more accurate
than using qpcr
we also compare different saline we
compare bicursi cells npc9 because cells
is a head and neck cancer cell and with
a high low basal level of upper bacteria
expression
and pc9 is a lung cancer saline that
expresses a very low basal level of
appropriate qa so when we treat the
cells with trans cytopin and interferon
alpha we observe a very strong induction
of appropriate ux pressure
gases cells but a very slight induction
in a pc9 cells that is barely detectable
by western blood we were not able to
detect at all upper bacteria at the
protein level in pc9 cells however by
digital pcr we were able to detect a
strong induction of upper back
reactivity after treatment in pc-96 so
again this results suggest that digital
pcr is more sensitive here to detect
ongoing activity after the bqa in a
cancer cell lines that express a very
low level of apoptosis something that we
were not able to do by western blood
finally we were interesting to know if
we can apply directly this digital pcr
method to detect the ongoing activity of
approbate qa in patient tumor samples
do so we collect here uci blood cancer
samples from patients with blood cancer
and we monitor ongoing activity of
robobacteria using our digital pcie and
we were able to detect a wide range of
activity across these patients
interestingly we were able to identify
which patients accumulate a high level
of upper bacterium
or probate reactivity and so you can
imagine in the future we can use this
digital pcr isf to monitor ongoing
activity affordability we're going to
try to identify which patient we can
treat for example with atr inhibitors
that i show you at the beginning can
specifically target and kill cancer
cells that express a high level of upper
bacteria so in the future we would like
to try to see if we can use this digital
pcr to identify this patient that should
be treated with rtr inhibitors and to
try to kill these cancer cells with a
higher upper bacterial expression
i would like to finish by i thank people
in my labs that perform this work first
peggy jalil a postdoc in my lab and son
hoo ho a grad student in my lab that
performed most of the experiment i
showed you today and also i would like
to thank my collaborator mike lawrence
that helped us to identify parent
editing site in patient human supports
that after that we developed as a
digital pcr
thank you very much and i'm happy to
address any question
thank you dr busan for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
given the use of dpcr to monitor
appleback activity and efforts with atr
inhibitor can you comment more about the
potential of following rna editing
events as a companion diagnostics
and what still needs to be done
so there's really the goal of cssa is to
be able to see how we can easily uh
using in clinic by collecting
when we collect tumor samples and to
very quickly address if this tumor
express or not appropriate until now the
only way we add is to a second the tumor
and look at upper bacterial mutation or
probability expression at mrna level
however the main challenge
by doing by second thing is that can
takes a few days or weeks to get the
results and so for the patient it's not
ideal if you want to get treated with
the native inhibitors for example and so
what is the goal of this digital pcr is
to be able to
quickly address if the tumor expresses
bacteria in a few hours and so currently
we can uh give a result in less than
five hours
and so it will be very
useful in clinic if we want to use as a
diagnostic tool to establish a treatment
for the patient
all right thank you
next question
some measurements were done with qpcr
and some with dpcr would you mind
sharing your thoughts on how you chose
which technique to use
so we first used a qpcr because
it was easier to develop primers
but what we quickly realized is in
certain situations qpcr do not correlate
necessarily with digital pcr and it's
like an example i'll show you where
sometimes the protein is still present
in the cells where uh the mrna is not so
really looking at digital pcr is really
looking directly at the protein level
that's something not possible with as a
qpcr so that's what is the advantage
here is a direct measurement of the
enzymatic activity of upper bacteria and
not an indirect
measurement of juice mrna levels that do
not necessarily reflect
to ongoing activity in a sample so
that's what is the reason why here we
are mostly interesting to use the
digital pcr because we can directly
monitor the ongoing activity of operator
directly and not through and direct
essay
all right thank you
next question
if there's a spatial correlation i.e
with epithelial cells
is there also a temporal correlation
where depending on the stage of cancer
there is an increase in apple back
activity contributing to tuber
mutagenesis
we're still not clear when when and
where the upper back
is expressed in cancer we know that
certain cancers express a lot of upper
bacteria
and have accumulated a lot of
photobacteria mutation
but in other cancers i do not accumulate
aprobacteria mutation so it's still not
clear
why certain type of tumor expresses
acrobatic va and why
other ones do not so i think it will be
still interesting in the future to try
to to better understand the mechanisms
that regulate hypobacteria expression in
cancer to determine how cancer cells
deregulate acrobatic expression to
induce a mutation and promote cancer
development
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
was it difficult to incorporate dpcr
into your experimental plans were the
data easy to interpret
yes it was very uh
easy to develop this
essay
the main challenge we are is to find
primers that specifically
recognize uh the wild type of the
mutated version of a tts so it took us a
little bit more time to find the perfect
primers that to not
uh
recognize the wrong seconds so that was
the main challenge for this essay but
once a primer were developed it's just
very very easy uh
to to monitor and uh the analysis of
percentage of running editing
was very is very easy uh to to obtain
because the software basically calculate
everything for us
so so only the design of the primer can
be a little bit challenging for that and
but once the primer are developed it's
very easy to run
all right thank you dr busan do you have
any final comments for our audience
uh
no yes my my only advice is really
is
it's really like the design of the
primer when you want to develop a
digital pcr essay for x reasons is take
a lot of time to think about how the
primary and test different primers
with synthetic oligonucleotide to make
sure the specificity specificity of the
primer so i think that's the main
challenge using digital pcr is it takes
a little bit more time versus a qpcr to
develop the primers but once the primers
develop it's choose a very easy
method to to apply
thank you again dr busan for your time
today and your important research
and we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be
viewed on demand lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you